hey Vsauce Michael here and this week I
am in San Francisco I just flew in a
couple of days ago so I've been busy
traveling but new episodes of regular
shows like IMG and dong are coming soon
but in the meantime rather than post
nothing I figured I would share things
that have been on my mind for instance
go back to the Golden Gate Bridge
footage there her that's the girl I sat
next to on the flight
turns out she's an immunology researcher
at a university in Italy she's studying
these parasitic worms in Africa that
infect people but then leave those
people immune to things like diabetes
and allergies in fact if you cure these
people of the worm infection they once
again become susceptible to things like
diabetes and allergies it's really
incredible so I guess good luck girl on
the plane to solving that because it
sounds awesome on the flight I also did
a bunch of reading I read this entire
book the history of Britain in really
tiny little bite-sized chunks now the
thing that really blew my mind was about
Ireland and the potato famine in the
1840s so many people died or left the
country because of that famine that to
this day the population of Ireland is
still lower than it was a hundred and
fifty years ago before the famine
speaking of things like people and birth
rates breathing earth is an amazing
website you can just sit there and let
the site visually show you based on
recent statistics where people are being
born and dying and how frequently a blue
Sun represents a birth and a black dot
represents a death
this is a picture of Anne Hathaway
so is this except this Anne Hathaway is
much much older and she's also quite
famous this Anne Hathaway was the wife
of William Shakespeare now we don't have
a photograph of her because photography
as we know it today wasn't even invented
until 200 years after that Anne Hathaway
died this is the first permanent
photograph ever taken by mankind it's a
view from a window in France taken in
1836 two years later in 1838 this
photograph was taken and what's
significant about it is that it's the
first photograph ever taken that had
people in it if you look down here for
instance you can see a man at a water
pump modern colorization zuv the image
have also claimed to have discovered
other people in the picture now none of
them are very clear which is why we
should talk about Robert Cornelius I
actually hid this portrait in the
beginning of the most recent IMG and the
reason it's significant is that this
picture is the first portrait ever taken
it's the first capturing of light
reflected off a human's face think of it
this way there is no other photograph of
anybody older than this this is the
oldest human we have a photographic
record of finally here's a picture that
IMG would be proud of a photo of a
musical parody group called the horrible
CERN girls formed out of employees at
CERN the initials of their name in
French are CER in but why should we care
about this picture well in 1992 Tim
berners-lee uploaded this photo to a
website making this image the very first
photographic image ever on the Internet
but here is something that has never
happened along the border
and Bhutan is a mountain called game
carpal insome at 24,000 800 feet high it
is the tallest mountain in the world
that mankind has yet to reach the top of
the local government prohibits
mountaineering in the region which means
it might be left unconquered for quite
some time making it one of just many
things on earth that we have yet to
explore in a couple of days we'll have a
new episode of dong so be sure to
subscribe to Vsauce and as always thanks
for watching
[Music]
you